the Sacramento Sheriff's Department will
release new information today after one
of its vehicles hit a protester a
witness says that vehicle drove away
without helping the 61 year old woman
she was involved in a protest Saturday
over the police shooting death of
Stephon Clarke Maria varial is at the
California State Capitol where a
lawmaker is calling for greater police
transparency Maria good morning good
morning a state senator is filing a bill
today that would make investigation
information on police shootings
available to the public right now it is
not available to just everyone this
comes as law enforcement is
investigating the Stephon Clarke case as
well as Saturday night's incident the
Sacramento Sheriff's Department contends
the collision with the pedestrian
occurred as its SUV moved to avoid being
vandalized it looked like she was trying
to get out of the way and it looked like
the patrol vehicle accelerated forward
and struck her violently with a thud and
she went down officials say the woman
was treated for minor injuries
reportedly bruises on her arm and the
back of her head she was among hundreds
who took to the streets Saturday night
after Friday's release of an independent
autopsy
it showed that Stephon Clark was shot
eight times by police in the back or
side none coming from the front
the autopsy report contradicts the
police department's earlier statement
which said Clark was facing the officers
and advancing toward them when they
opened fire police voluntarily released
body cam video three days later in the
Sacramento shooting we saw the police
department immediately release the body
camera videos they didn't have - state
senator nancy skinner is introducing
legislation today calling for the
mandatory release of investigation
reports looking into police use of
deadly force including related body cam
videos they could complete that
investigation and right now they have no
obligation to release it to the public
and you and I have no right to get any
of the reports related to that
investigation
my bill would change that other similar
bills have been filed and failed right
now we do know that this one is expected
to see some stiff police organization
opposition but Senator Skinner does tell
me she expects if the police officer
safety is in jeopardy there exceptions
can be made she also says she has a lot
of support coming from civil rights
organizations that include the ACLU and
black lives matter John
Mariah thanks we'll be watching for that
release of information today